do you think aliens have consciousness
if they're organic
so organic yes connected to caution i
mean i i think any any system which is
going to bootstrap itself up from
planetary origins i mean
let me finish this and then i come onto
something else but uh from from
planetary origins is going to face
similar constraints and those
constraints are going to be addressed in
similar basic engineering ways and i
think it will be cellular and i think it
will have electrical charges and i think
it will have to
be selected in populations over time and
all of these things will tend to give
rise to the same processes as the
simplest fix to a difficult problem so i
would expect it to be conscious yes and
i would expect it to
resemble life on earth in
many ways
when i was about i guess 15 or 16 i
remember reading a book by fred hoyle
um called the black cloud
which
i was a budding biologist at the time
and this was the first time i'd come
across someone that really challenging
the heart of biology and saying
you're you are far too parochial you you
know you're thinking about life as
carbon based here's a here's a life form
which is kind of dust interstellar dust
that on a on a on a solar system scale
um
and i
you know it's a novel but i felt
enormously challenged by that novel
because i hadn't occurred to me
how limited my thinking was
uh how how
narrow-minded i was being and here was
it was a great physicist with a
completely different conception of what
life could be
and since then i've seen him attacked uh
in in various ways and i
i'm kind of reluctant to say the attacks
make more sense to me than than the
original story which is to say
even in terms of
information processing if you're on that
scale and there's a limit to the speed
of light how quickly can something think
if you're needing to
broadcast across the
the the solar system
is going to be slow it's not going to
hold a conversation with you on the kind
of timelines that fred hoyle was
imagining at least not by
any easy way of doing it assuming that
the speed of light is a limit
um
and and then again you
you really can't this is something
richard dawkins argued long ago and i do
think he's right there is no other way
to generate this level of complexity
than natural selection nothing else can
do it you need populations
and you need selection in populations
and a kind of an isolated
um
interstellar
cloud
again it's unlimited time and maybe
there's no problems with distance but
you need to have
a certain frequency of generational time
to generate a serious level of
complexity
um and
i just have a feeling it's never going
to work
well
as far as we know so natural selection
evolution is really powerful tool here
on earth but there could be other
mechanisms so whenever i don't know if
you're familiar with
cellular automata
but complex systems that
have really simple components and
seemingly move based on simple rules
when they're taken as a whole
really interesting complexity emerges
i don't know what the pressures on that
are it's not really selection but
interesting complexity seems to emerge
and that's not well understood exactly
why is that the difference between
complexity and evolution
so some of the work we're doing on the
origin of life is is is thinking about
how does
uh
how do genes arise how does information
arise in biology
and thinking about it from the point of
view of reacting co2 with hydrogen what
do you get well what you're going to get
is carboxylic acids then amino acids
it's quite hard to make nucleotides um
and
it's possible to make them and it's been
done and it's been done following this
pathway as well but you make trace
amounts
and so the next question assuming that
this is the right way of seeing the
question which maybe it's just not but
let's assume it is
is well how do you reliably make more
nucleotides then how do you become more
complex and better at
becoming a nucleotide generating machine
and the answer is well you need positive
feedback loops
some form of auto catalysis so
that can work and we know it happens in
biology if this nucleotide for example
catalyzes co2 fixation then you're going
to increase the rate of flux through the
whole system and you're going to
effectively steepen the driving force to
make more nucleotides
um
and this can be inherited because
there are forms of membrane heredity
that you can have and there are
effectively you can if a cell divides in
two and it's got a lot of stuff inside
it and that stuff is basically bound as
a
network which is capable of regenerating
itself
then it will
inevitably regenerate itself and so you
can develop greater complexity
but everything that i've said depends on
the underlying rules of thermodynamics
there is no evolvability about that it's
simply an inevitable
outcome of your starting point
assuming that you're able to
increase the driving force through the
system you will generate more of the
same you'll expand on what you can do
but you'll never get anything different
than that and it's only when you
introduce
information into that as a gene as a as
a kind of
small stretch of rna
which can be random stretch
then you get real evolvability then you
get biology as we know it but you also
have selection as we know it
yeah i mean i don't know how to think
about information
um that's the kind of memory of the
systems it's not
yet at the local level it's propagation
of copying yourself and changing and
improving your adaptability to the
environment
you